when down meets up that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
now watching Biden give a speech is like
watching a slow-motion car crash you
can't help but Rubberneck but under the
trickle-down economic three Theory three
quarters of U.S Industries grew more
consecrated I mean excuse me consecrated
I'm thinking I didn't go to Mass
[Applause]
ah but as sad as that is for America
it's not Biden's biggest obstacle to
re-election the biggest obstacle is that
poll after poll is showing that
Americans just hate the Biden economy
just 20 percent of Voters believe this
country is headed in the right direction
74 say the nation is on the wrong track
let me tell you something about this
moment we have had this sustained period
of 70 percent about a year now the last
two periods in the history of this poll
that we've had this kind of sustained
negativity about the direction of the
country was before the 92 election and
before the 2008 election both of those
changed the party controlling the White
House
oh it's stunning now you know that
killed Chuck Todd to report but it's
devastating it was just a few weeks ago
that Biden was trying to act like
America was sitting on some record
growth not a lot of trickled down from
my parents kitchen table when I was
growing up
so we're changing we decided to replace
this Theory with what the Press is now
called bidenomics I don't know what the
hell that is
but it's working
it's working of course that speech flops
so today the genius is over at the White
House decided to roll Poor Joe out again
this time with a new branding strategy
but is the public buying this
Dynamics is working that's just not true
whatever world they're living in they
may be working but they're not working
in our world
is your grocery bill higher absolutely
yeah as a matter of fact seems like
everything is just going up in terms of
prices it's ridiculous he's done more to
hurt this country than any other
president before him right now it's just
another way of saying restore the
American dream who wrote that for him
Middle America is definitely a thing of
the past I mean he's destroyed a lot so
when you hear by Dynamics what do you
think idiocy
absolute idiocy
stupidity failure how we screwed up the
country that's what I I come up with
brilliant well I've got my own
definition of bionomics it's an economic
theory whereby the closer you are to the
Biden family the more likely you are to
get rich
and exactly what part of Biden's
economic record are we actually supposed
to be celebrating tonight well why don't
we ask Fed chair Jerome Powell core
inflation I don't see us getting to two
percent this year or next year I see us
getting there the year after 2025 yeah
core inflation two percent
for a long time long time we will be
restrictive as long as we need to be so
restrictive let's just say what you mean
interest rates are going to remain high
and persistent not you know inflation
inflation's not going to be transitory
high prices are going to be there for
beleaguered Americans to deal with and
then Powell really came clean linking
bidenomics to the r word
I think there's a significant
probability that there will be a
downturn as well though but isn't up to
not to me the most likely case
that's the hard Landing scenario or just
this I wasn't even thinking of hard
Landing I was thinking of even a even a
you know a recession
hard Landing would be the good case
now you see what I mean the button team
thought that they could message away you
know all their bad numbers like the fact
that our economic growth this year is
going to be a pathetic 1.6 and next year
it drops even lower to one percent
putting us at or below the rest of other
the other member countries now only
could Biden call it restoring the
American dream when Americans are having
to abandon their dream of owning a home
with home sales dropping over 20 percent
now remember the one year that Biden did
have strong growth that was in 2020
route one was before the Fallout of his
inflationary spending and the anti-oil
and gas policies actually took effect
Biden's performance today was when you
look at it kind of the ultimate study in
cynicism
to go to speak to a country where
workers are suffering and scared and
your plan is to keep the same economic
team the same economic policies that's
gonna they're gonna produce the same
pain to Americans
your answer is to unveil a branding
campaign using your own name
a real president would see these numbers
and heads would roll
he'd say that one percent growth is
unacceptable it's intolerable a real
president would convene leaders from
both parties and likely conclude that
let's give Americans some tax relief
let's change our trade policy starting
with that idiotic 800 diminished de
minimis duty-free package giveaway to
China
and actually help American workers and
small businesses for a change
tell them let's get America moving again
how do we do that
instead we get more puffery from Biden
Toadies or in this case a bullfrog
today American workers have more job
opportunities and can earn a better wage
because President Biden cares about
upward Mobility
he cares well we don't need to hear JB
about how much Joe Biden cares about us
or all the life lessons he learned from
his dad and his grandfather
we need less marketing and more results
the Democrats like to say that one of
Trump's biggest biggest problems is that
he never admits when he's wrong okay
well Trump's policies on the economy
worked magnificently now check this out
from December 2019 from CNN of all
places as 2019 comes to a close the U.S
economy earns its highest ratings in
almost two decades overall 76 percent
rate economic conditions in the U.S
today as very or somewhat good
significantly more than those who said
so at least the same time last year at
67 percent this is the highest share to
say the economy is good since February
2001.
in other words Trump didn't have to
spend his economic numbers because they
spoke for themselves
he was both tougher on China than Biden
and delivered better growth at this
point in his presidency
it took a china-generated virus and a
prolonged Democrat shutdown in blue
states to stop the Trump economy in his
presidency
think of all the Office Buildings
bustling and the Christmas parties that
were buzzing in December of 2019.
and now two and a half years into
Biden's presidency we see half empty
Office Buildings which may never be full
again
that's by nomics and that's the angle
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else